we want x-men we want x-men
or or how about a dick joke instead
welcome to the heavy spoiler show i'm
your host paul aka
ralph bona gonna put you in a coma in
this video we're breaking down both
credit scenes from the finale of one
division
the pair set up a lot of things in the
mcu and throughout this video we'll be
discussing how they can be taken
and what they imply for the future both
spoilers ahead so if you haven't seen
the episode then i'll recommend that you
turn off now
if you enjoy the video then please drop
a thumbs up and make sure you subscribe
to the channel for breakdowns like this
each and every day
without the way thank you for clicking
this now let's get into those two scenes
okay so the first one picks up almost
immediately after wonder flies out of
west view in the town's center
jimmy is directing fbi agents so that
they can provide medical and
psychological attention to the citizens
who've been stuck in an episode of
fatherhood's best for the last week
due to monica's comments on authority
looking good on him
i'm guessing that wu has been put in
charge of cleanup and because of his
work in west view he'll probably be
moving up the pole
now juxtaposing this hayward will
probably have a pole moving up him
because he's going to jail is that is
that the best jokes of course yeah me
anyway
at this point monica has fully become
photon and she now possesses superpowers
which have clearly caught the attention
of someone else this special agent calls
wander to the theater
which is showing a film called tanhauser
gate
now this is actually a callback to blade
runner namely roy batty who discussed
the things he'd witnessed as he was
dying
the character stated i've watched sea
beams glitter in the dark
near the tanhauser gate now this
actually foreshadows the journey that
monaco will be going on
but we'll get into that more in just a
bit the name tan hauser actually refers
to a knight from german folklore
who had to journey into the underworld
to find a pagan queen
much like how monica had to travel into
the hex to find the skull at which
yes we're reaching inside the agent
transforms into a skrull
and unfortunately it isn't alice's
daughter who was friends with her in
captain marvel
however she brings an important mission
and the character says that she's been
sent by an old friend of monica's mother
now this could apply to talos or nick
fury but i'm signing more with the
latter for a number of reasons
firstly fury is with the skrulls at the
end of far from home
and they're journeying through space the
film actually takes place
eight months after this show so it seems
like he may have met with monica
and then they traveled out into the
vastness of the stars in order to
complete a mission
during this time talos was of course
masquerading as fury
and therefore it makes sense that he
selected him to stay on earth whilst he
and monica journeyed into the cosmos
we know that monika will be featuring in
captain marvel too
and as we discovered in endgame she's
policing a lot of planets throughout the
universe
now this episode pretty much confirmed
through the dark hole that agents of
shield is not canon in the mcu
therefore if we stick with the main
timeline then they were disbanded after
the winter soldier
thus fury has probably been looking for
a new agency to work with
and this will likely be sought in both
the comics in mcu it's clear that they
dealt with space matters
and it's only after the events of the
snap that the latter version changed
direction
with their acting director no longer
being an acting director
i think that sword will be traveling
back to the stars and they will be led
by monica who has filled her mother's
shoes
the sword logo on her uniform is clearly
there for a reason
and who knows they might even meet daisy
who too travelled into space after
agents of shield
look i'm begging you i'm begging just
please just make a cannon
now cut to the second post credit scene
and we travel to what i believe is
wonder goal mountain
more like wanda board mountain i'm all
right no
no now why i believe that this is the
case is because of the darkhold
it was actually in a chamber known as
the dark hold
in this very mountain that kuthon wrote
his book of black magic the darkhold
and this is a powerman possession that
ties heavily into the series
though i rode that mephisto train until
me and eric voss were the last
passengers on it
i've actually gone on to think that
catholic is the true one behind it all
in the comics he was actually the being
that bestowed wanda's powers upon her
when she was a young girl
and as we learned in episode 8 she was
always a witch
even in this continuity the fact he also
wrote the book ties in heavily to this
and the villain possessed quicksilver in
the comics much like how agatha
possessed
ralph boner no i don't know why i'm
laughing at
what what a troll that was now speaking
of bonus we catch wonder getting a bit
of mourning glory in the cabin that's
surrounded by
i honestly don't know why i'm laughing
i'm 32 right
and i i shouldn't be finding the word
boner that funny but never mind
now she strolls back inside and it's
revealed that her scarlet witch version
is on the astral plane reading through
the darkhold it's at this point that she
hears the voices of her children
who are still clearly out there now what
does this mean
well there's a number of ways you can
take it either the dark lord could on
has manifested them as a trick to make
wonder dull deeper into the book
or they're trapped in the astral plane
this is a sort of
afterlife and it could be where the
spirits have gone
in doctor strange we saw the titular
character doing a similar sort of thing
to what plays out here
and therefore we can shut down the idea
that there are now two wonders
i feel like they're going on a sort of
dark phoenix trip here with the alter
ego within her being something that
could potentially turn to the dark side
and destroy the world however she always
has agatha to turn to
and she will likely become a mentor to
the character similar to what she is in
the comics
as for her children they scream out for
help and sound in pain
so it makes sense that wonder would try
and track them down
now we know going forward that the
character will be appearing in doctor
strange in the multiverse of madness
and it's likely that her trying to bring
them back is what causes things to go
haywired hate like hayward terrible
anyway
shout outs andrew lumax on twitter for
pointing out that we never actually see
the kids vanish
and that someone could have snuck in
there and took them out before the hex
closed
however i think something different and
i believe that wanda will try and
manifest her children through the
darkhold
but in doing so she'll also bring
forward a dark entity
in the comics both billy and tommy were
originally extensions of mephisto's soul
and they were used as a way to bring the
villain to earth however our heroes
managed to stop him
the kids disappeared in the process much
in the same way that they did at the end
of the series
but they have returned to the comics now
as fully fledged characters
i know i've touched upon this in other
videos but just in case you missed them
the pair did post photos showing that
they were in london during the time that
doctor strange 2 was being filmed
and therefore it's a safe bet that they
will return
going ahead there's also the white
vision who is still out there
in the episode it looked like he was
gonna go all terminator 2 on everybody
but vision managed to get through to him
and restore his memories
this included his life with wonder
before the snap and he said
i am vision before flying off now the
character is still alive
and he will likely be the person that
has to rain wonder in from going off the
deep end
i'm kind of torn on this as i do feel
pretty much everyone who dies in the mcu
eventually gets brought back
and i did want some real consequences
from infinity war
wunder said goodbye to the memory of
vision in the finale and it seems like
we're kind of going back on things just
allowing him to return
however i love paul bettany and do you
want to see vision more
summer i suppose it is a get out of jail
free card that i can live with
these really feel like marwell's first
family to me now and now that's
typically the fantastic four
i feel like they've slotted into the
role really nicely i would love to see
wonder bring them back
now obviously i'd love to hear your
thoughts on the post credits scene so
make sure you comment below and let me
know
as a thank you for interacting with the
video you'll be entered into a prize
through on the 31st of march
in which we're giving away three copies
of a marvel 4k box set of your choice
all you have to do to be on the chance
of winning is like the video make sure
you subscribe with notifications on and
drop a comment below with your thoughts
on the post credits scenes
the winners of last month's competition
are on screen right now so that's you
then message me on twitter heavyspoilers
if you want something else to watch then
make sure you check out our full
breakdown of episode 9 which will be
linked on screen right now
we've gone over the entire thing from
top to bottom so it's definitely worth
checking out if you want to know more
by the way thank you for sitting through
this i've been paul i'll see you next
time
take care peace